in the last video we started with the
2x2 matrix a is equal to 1 2 4 3 and we
use the fact that lambda is an
eigenvalue lambda is an eigenvalue
eigenvalue of a if and only if the
determinant of lambda times the identity
matrix in this case it's the 2 by 2
identity matrix minus a is equal to 0
this gave us a characteristic polynomial
and we solved for that and we said well
the eigenvalues for a are lambda is
equal to 5 and lambda is equal to
negative 1 that's what we saw in the
last in the last video we said that if
you were trying to solve a times some
eigenvector is equal to lambda times
that eigenvector the two lambdas which
this equation can be solved for are the
lambdas 5 and minus 1 if we assume
assuming assuming a non zero eigen
vectors assuming nonzero non zero eigen
vectors eigen vectors so we have our
eigen values but that's you know then I
don't even call that half the battle
what we really want is our eigen vectors
and our eigen values so let's see if we
can do that so if we manipulate if we
manipulate this equation a little bit
and we manipulated in the past actually
even come up with this statement over
here we can you know rewrite this over
here as the zero vector is equal to
lambda times my eigen vectors minus a
times my eigen vector just subtracted a
V from both sides and we know lambda
times some eigen vectors the same thing
as lambda times the identity matrix
times that I ghen vector so all I'm
doing is rewriting this like that you
multiply the identity matrix times an
eigen vector or times any vector you
just going to get that vector so these
two things are equivalent - a V a V
that's still going to be equal to the
zero vector so far all I've done is
manipulated this thing and this is
really how we got to that thing up there
then you take the you factor out the V
so to speak because we know that matrix
vector products exhibit the distributive
property and we get lambda times the
identity matrix minus a times times my
eigenvector have got to be equal to zero
or another way to say it is for any for
any for any for any lambda eigenvalue
let me write it for any eigen value
lambda eigenvalue lambda the
eigenvectors that correspond to that
lambda we can call that the eigen space
the eigenspace for lambda so that's a
new word eigen space again space eigen
space just means all of the eigenvectors
that correspond to some eigenvalue the
eigen space for that for some particular
eigenvalue is going to be equal to the
set of vectors that satisfy this
equation well the set of vectors that
satisfy this equation is just the null
space it's just the null space of that
right there so it's equal to the null
space of this matrix right there the
null space tricks of lambda times the
identity matrix n by n identity matrix
minus a and so everything I've done here
this is true this is the general case
but now we can apply this notion to this
matrix a right here so we know that v is
an eigen value so for let's say for
lambda is equal to 5 the eigenspace that
corresponds to 5 is equal to the null
space of what what is 5 times the
identity matrix 5 it's going to be the 2
by 2 identity matrix right 5 times the
identity matrix is just it's just 5 0 0
5 minus a that's just 1 2 4 3 so that is
equal to the null space the null space
of the matrix
5 minus 1 is 4 0 minus 2 is minus 2 0
minus 4 is minus 4 and then 5 minus 3 is
2 so the null space of this matrix right
here this matrix is just a actual number
of numerical representation of this
matrix right here the null space of this
matrix is the set of all of the vectors
that satisfy this or all of the
eigenvectors that correspond to this
eigenvalue or the eigenspace that
corresponds to the eigenvalue 5 these
are all equivalent statements so we just
need to figure out the null space of
this guy is all the vectors that satisfy
the equation 4 minus 2 minus 4 2 times
some eigenvector is equal to the 0
vector and the null space of a matrix is
equal to the null space of the reduced
row echelon form of a matrix so what's
the reduced row echelon form of this guy
well let's I guess a good starting point
let me keep my first row the same 4
minus 2 and let me replace my second row
with my second row plus my first row so
minus 4 plus 4 is 0 2 plus minus 2 is 0
now let me divide my first row by 4 and
I get 1 minus 1/2 and then I get 0 0 so
what's the null space of this this
corresponds to if V this times V 1 V 2
that's just another way of writing my
eigenvector v has got to be equal to the
0 vector or another way to say it is
that my first entry V 1 which
corresponds to this pivot column plus or
minus 1/2 times my second entry has got
to be equal to that 0 right there or V 1
is equal to 1/2 is equal to 1/2 V 2 and
so if I wanted to write all of the eigen
vectors that satisfy this so I could
write it this way my eigen space my
eigenspace that corresponds to lambda
equals 5 that corresponds to the
eigenvalue 5 is equal to the set
of all of the vectors v1 v2 that are
equal to some scaling factor real estate
say it's equal to T times what if we say
that v2 is equal to T so v2 is going to
be equal to T times 1 and then v1 is he
going to be equal to 1/2 times v2 or 1/2
times T one-half times T just like that
for any for any T is a member for any T
is a member of the real numbers and if
we wanted to we could scale this up
because any real number times you know
1/2 that would also be a you know a the
span let me do that actually it'll make
it a little bit cleaner actually I don't
have to do that so we could write the
eigenspace the eigenspace for the
eigenvalue v is equal to the span of the
vector of the vector one half and one so
it's a line in r2 those are all of the
eigen vectors that satisfy that that
work for the equation where the eigen
value is equal to 5 now what about when
the eigen value is equal to minus 1 and
the eigen value is equal to minus 1 so
let's do that case when lambda is equal
to minus 1 then we have then the we're
going to have the it's going to be the
null space so the eigenspace for lambda
is equal to minus 1 is going to be the
null space of lambda times our identity
matrix which is going to be minus 1 0 0
minus 1 all right it's going to be minus
1 times 1 0 0 1 which is just minus 1
there minus a so minus 1 2 4 3 and this
is equal to the null space of minus 1
minus 1 is minus 2 0 minus 2 is minus 2
0 minus 4 is minus 4 and minus 1 minus 3
is minus 4 and that's going to be equal
to the null space of the reduced row
echelon form of that
so the we can perform some row
operations right here let me just put it
in reduced row-echelon form so if I
replace my second row with my second row
plus two times my first row so I'll keep
the first row the same minus two minus
two and then my second row I'll replace
it with two times I'll replace it with
it plus two times the first or even
better I'm going to replace it with it
plus minus two times the first so minus
four plus four is zero minus 4 plus 4 is
zero and then if I divide the top row by
minus two the reduced row echelon form
of this matrix right here or this matrix
right here is going to be one one zero
so the eigenspace that corresponds to
the eigenvalue minus one eigen space
corresponds to the eigenvalue minus one
is equal to the null space of this guy
right here or it equals the it's the set
of vectors that satisfy this equation 1
1 0 0 and then you have V 1 V 2 is equal
to 0 or you get V 1 plus not these
aren't vectors these are just values V 1
plus V 2 is equal to 0 sorry is equal to
0 because 0 is just equal to that thing
right there so 1 times V 1 plus 1 times
V 2 is going to be equal to that 0 right
there or I could write V 1 is equal to
minus V 2 or if we say that V 2 is equal
to T we could say V 1 is equal to minus
D or we could say that the eigenspace
for the eigenvalue minus 1 is equal to
all of the vectors all of the vectors V
1 V 2 that are equal to some scalar T
times V 1 is minus T and V 2 is plus T
or you could say this is equal to the
span of the vector minus 1 and 1 so
let's just graph this a little bit just
to understand what we just did we were
able to find two eigen values for this
five and minus one and we're able to
find all of the
factors that are essentially the or we
were able to find a set of vectors that
are the eigenvectors that correspond to
each of these eigenvalues so let's graph
them so if we go to our two let me draw
my axis it's my vertical axis that's my
horizontal axis so all of the vectors
that correspond to lambda equal five are
aligned the line one-half one so or the
span of one-half one so that is one that
is one so you go one half and one just
like that so that's that vector spanning
vector but anything along the span of
this all the multiples of this are going
to be valid eigenvectors or anything
along that line all of the vectors when
you draw them in standard position point
to a point on that line all of these
vectors any vector on there is going to
be a valid eigenvector and the
corresponding eigenvalue is going to be
equal to five so you give me you give me
this guy right here when you apply the
transformation it's going to be five
times this guy you give me you give me
if this guy is X T of X is going to be
five times this guy whatever vector you
give along this line the transformation
of that guy and the transformation is
literally multiplying it by the matrix a
where did I have the matrix a the matrix
a right up there you're essentially just
scaling this guy by five in either
direction this is for lambda equal 5 and
for lambda equals one is the span of
this vector which is minus 1 minus 1 1
which looks like this it will look so
this vector looks like that
we care about the span of it so anything
any vector in this set any vector that
when you draw in standard position lies
or points two points on this line will
be an eigenvector
for the eigenvalue minus one so lambda
equals minus one so if you take well
let's say you take the spanning vector
here you apply the transformation you're
going to get minus one times it so this
is X the transformation of X is going to
be that right
same length just in the opposite
direction if you have this guy right
here you apply the transformation it's
going to be in the same spanning line
just like that so the two eigen spaces
for the matrix where did I write it I
think it was the matrix 1 2 3 1 2 4 3
the two eigenvalues were 5 and minus 1 5
and minus 1 and then it has an infinite
number of eigenvectors so they actually
create two eigenspaces each of them
correspond to one of the eigenvalues and
these lines represent those two
eigenspaces you give me any vector in
either of these sets and they're going
to be an eigenvector or you can be any
vet I'm using the word vector too much
give me any vector in either of these
sets and they will be an eigenvector for
our matrix a and then depending which
line it is we know what their
transformation is going to be it's going
to be on this guy you take the
transformation the resulting vector is
going to be five times the vector if you
take one of these eigenvectors and you
transform it the resulting
transformation of the vector is going to
be minus one times that vector anyway we
now know what eigenvalues eigenvectors
eigenspaces are and even better we know
how to actually find them